[Musique]
fille ou garçon
voici les beats depuis quelques temps
l'europe découvre leurs cheveux longs
leurs harmonies cas où leurs guitares
mai aux etats-unis cette génération
spontanée a vu le jour il ya dix ans
dans une grange de 100 franchises boucle
depuis le mouvement se déplacer vers
l'est et aujourd'hui le quartier général
des beatniks et greenwich village le
saint-germain-des-prés new yorkais le
beatnik c'est dit-on le battu celui qui
abandonne qui ne veut plus lutter celui
qui refuse de participer
pourtant quand on sait qu'il se range
derrière la bannière que porto bob dylan
et joan baez
on ne peut pas ne pas trouver un
complète cette définition le beatnik et
surtout un révolté épris de liberté
meizu la révolte le mènera t'il
sera-t-il poète ou clochard
ici aux etats unis le mot but nick est
souvent associée au mode drogué est ce
que c'est vrai
les drogues sont très important à notre
vie les dragons ouanna et les styles
sont très populaires à ce moment car il
change le conscient et ce moment un
révolution intérieure emprunt place aux
états unis et les dragons se sont et
catalyst d'échanger une autre conscience
est tous des drogués en ce moment même
jésus était une pique nique très pur
très rare mais il y là nous il nous a
présenté les d idéal de la propreté
volontaire mais pourquoi il voulait
selon lui la balle moi je sais c'est
confortable
avec l'été venu d'amérique d'angleterre
du monde entier ou plus simplement de
paris ils ont retrouvé leur quartier de
prédilection la huchette
saint michel les quais de la seine le
vert-galant non-violent cheveux longs
bourse plate guitariste de café
printemps de trottoir il étonne et
scandalise de bourgeois par leurs tenues
anti conformiste
avant cela s'appelait la bohème
[Musique]
maintenant ce sont les beatniks
un nom de les écrase un autre un lien
les unit leur jeunesse
vous êtes mitnick oui on avait des
pièces que ça veut dire pour jouer tant
qu'il est unique c'est une question
qu'on est contre la société je vois un
esprit vous êtes contre la guerre aux
contrôles contre la guerre aussi et
aussi quand la société soit ici ça oui
ce n'est pas tant la journée quelle est
la journée dominique près comme en ce
moment devant quatre ans à 6h30 quand
les bleus passent ce que le progrès
attention là ya du beau père muller qui
me manque j'ai bloqué ce que je mets à
vingt six brigades en tout cas charme
alors là ensuite monaco continue qui
tout en débutant popov et l'espérance
nous conte sombre et oui après faso qui
sera dimanche et pas pouvoir être à coup
quoi on se raser pour vous vous rasez
pas encore c'est pas le cas il ya une
très grande amitié je crois qu'il faut
noter entre les français les hollandais
les allemands et les anglais
je crois que nous s'ils veulent la paix
aussi bien qu'ils soient allemands des
hollandais que français nous voulons
tous la paix qu'est ce que vous mangez à
midi le sous titre phare sera pas
intégralement une baguette par jour
et puis ils seront deux fois au pmc
populaire la soirée la société nous
disperse dans le détail on est projeté à
100 100 kilomètres à l'heure dans toutes
les directions tout temps en temps ses
craintes sur un platane alors comment
réagissez-vous dans sa belle d'abord je
me retranche un peu aussi mais parce que
j'ai besoin de me retrouver l'essai de
deux savoir ce que c'est que vous fait
que dormir
savoir ce que c'est que je sais pas moi
de cerner un petit peu de
et désirent les trucs comme ça vous
savez qu'une des choses que les gens
vous reproche le plus c'est de ne pas
travailler
est ce que c'est vrai on a parmi nous
qui cherchent du travail que nous ne
cherchons pas du travail mettant robot
ce que nous recherchons c'est un travail
mais toutefois apporter quelque chose
qui nous juge ne pourra apporter quelque
chose mais dont comme vous reporter aux
meubles monsieur linh aux trois
photographies actuellement c'était
possible si c'était possible je pense je
ferai jamais ma main et c'est ça m'était
donné vous êtes contre quel genre de
travail travail du bureau il faut
pointer le matin il faut il est en fait
un travail tête est à la chaîne ou alors
être pire aux strates permutter de sa
vie dans tron dans un bureau ça ne
m'intéresse pas j'aime bien travailler
vous m'aviez dit tout à l'heure on nous
prend pour des blues en noir et c'est
pas ça du tout voyez nous préciser ce
que vous voulez dire par là que le
blouson noir et le beatnik sont deux
formes de révolte c'est nous nous
révoltons pas la même manière parce que
le pouce en noir lui au stade
première la révolte et de l'instinct à
la révolte de la bagarre du vol mais et
nous nous nous réfléchissons à une
révolte mais c'est déjà au stade
supérieur quand est ce que vous êtes
influencé par certains romanciers ou par
certains chanteurs annuel en or dylan
par exemple à melbourne il est très bien
il a des chansons contre la guerre je
prends un dylan mais c'est très bien
pour moi
quand on vous parle de charles trenet
par exemple pour ses campagnes
non pas du tout et c'est dallas la
poésie monsieur l'aps c'est pas de la
poésie dans ce qu'elle est chez lui
c'est la même joie c'est horrible
comment est ce que vous voyez votre
avenir dans quelques années comment vous
voyez-vous par exemple dans dix ans
d'ici le jour
je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà
réfléchir à 4
oui c'est exact et les charges y
réfléchit
enfin je n'ai pas un jeu
[Musique]